welcome back to me rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Spider-Man across the spider
versus new trailer reveals that Miles
Morales is in quite a bit of trouble and
not just because his Crush can appear
over his bed at any moment I mean yikes
the villain of the sequel has been
announced as the spot voiced by Jason
Schwartzman Dr Jonathan own who uses
portals to evade and deceive his
opponents but he will reportedly be the
antagonist of both this movie and the
follow-up beyond the spider-verse yet he
doesn't really appear in this trailer
really the aggressor beating up on Miles
the most is Spider-Man 2099 Miguel
O'Hara Oscar Isaac when he was
introduced in that post credit scene to
the 2018 film what's that moment
actually unveiling another villain of
across the spiderverse well I think it's
more complicated than that so let's
break down McGill O'Hara's plan in this
movie and if he's not a prototypical
villain why he seems so at odds with
Miles and by the way I went more into
the animation details in my design
analysis and breakdown of the
spider-verse trailer in another video be
sure to check that out along with
Jessica Clement's Easter egg breakdown
she did such a great job identifying all
the Spider-Man cameos and I just love
that we got to tag team this one and
each cover it from different angles so
in the trailer we see Miguel O'Hara
looking pretty isolated and pretty
roughed up the guy's been through some
[ __ ] and he's often charging toward
Miles Morales chasing him down on the
end of York Super Highway and tackling
him into the pavement and then we get
this voiceover exchange between him and
Gwen Stacy who do you think you are
really we are supposed to be the good
guys we are yeah that doesn't sound good
really it sounds like the kind of oh the
grades are good
arguments that you hear movie villains
make all the time Miguel seems to be
going to some extremes crossing a moral
line hoping ends will justify the means
Phil Lord and Chris Miller explained it
this way to Gwen voice actress Haley
Steinfeld basically you get invited into
Oscar Isaac's cool spider Force you get
invited yeah into like the spider
society and
um and Miles doesn't
and you sort of can't tell him why so
it was comic run tying in with the
spider getting event in which all the
spider people face an existential threat
from the inheritors spider force does
center around Jessica Drew who doesn't a
kid at that point and Jessica Drew in
this movie is pregnant so there may be a
connection there but what I love about
this trailer is that it doesn't really
give anything away about the plot it's
just Vibes really introducing the themes
of Miles not really fitting in with the
broader Society of spider people and
promising dozens of awesome cameos from
the Multiverse and again we don't even
see the Ville in the spot but there is a
quick moment in which Miguel O'Hara
looks at a display screen that shows a
file of who I assume to be his daughter
Gabriella and the comics Miguel has a
son named Gabriel who's named after his
half-brother Gabriel and the son Gabriel
O'Hara takes Miguel's place at some
point based on the emotional intensity
Miguel seems to be bringing here I'm
gonna guess Gabriella died but since he
didn't seem to be carrying this weight
with him in the 2018 film I'm gonna
guess that Gabriella died recently so
sometime between Miguel crossing point
and fingers with the 60 Spider-Man and
that Meme at the end of the 2018 film
and meeting hundreds of other spider
people and setting up this whole Nexus
and Society he lost his daughter
something happened so I don't know if it
would really be accurate to call Miguel
a villain of this movie with such a
sympathetic backstory but what Lord
Miller always do really well is give all
of their characters deep emotional Wells
and justifiable motivations like Kingpin
he also lost his wife and kid he was
just trying to bring them back so really
all the characters are just pursuing
understandable goals that just collide
with each other so it's not really an
always pure of heart hero versus an evil
villain it's more just a protagonist
versus an antagonist which makes for a
better story so if Miguel did lose his
kid we gotta wonder how and why it seems
he's so afraid of Miles joining the
society also oh is someone at the door
of the blue dungeon oh it's Mt here to
talk about today's sponsor look guys
hosting videos like this on YouTube
Finds Me frequently fishing for
compliments but sometimes I just want to
fish for fish and that's when I play
fishing Clash fishing class lets me
travel all over the world to go fishing
in amazing locations and have some of
the most realistic fish Graphics I have
ever seen in a mobile game you can fish
from Shore or a boat all while sitting
in your favorite comfy chair at home and
as you play you'll be able to upgrade
your rods lures and fishing skills to
catch bigger rarer fish and if you're
really feeling like letting out your
inner Quint you can compete in weekly
competitions and events develop your
fishing skills you can even create your
own Clan to play with your friends and
family and compete against other players
and use code rockstars to get an awesome
20 value reward for free with my gift
code you'll get a unique Avatar one
mythical lure card 50 luck power-ups and
30 weight power ups to help you catch
bigger fish thanks Mt well there are two
key things that we learned from Lord
Miller's after party interview with
Haley Steinfeld one is that Miguel's
features Nueva York is based on the art
of Sid Mead which depicted an
aspirational future in Nueva York was
designed with deliberate artists
constriction lines left visible
underneath to convey it as a work in
progress as all Futures are when you
think about it and we actually see this
in the trailer with Miguel in a freeze
frame with animators storyboard lines
and notes to the Anchor conveying what
colors to fill them in with crimson red
and Imperial Violet crimson and Imperial
by the way not just shades of ink but
app descriptions of Miguel's violent
approach and multiversal Empire Building
Ambitions this description of Miguel and
Nuevo York actually matched director
Kent Powers past descriptions of the
spot as a character who begins as a work
in progress a rough draft with artists
blue construction lines that get more
and more spotted within can gradually
filled in as he gets a handle on his
powers and you gotta love this as a
series that celebrates art and ink dots
and frame rates and everything to
actually make this an element within the
story too so could the ink that
splatters on Dr Jonathan ohm to turn him
into the spot be a multiversal sickness
that threatens everyone linked to the
spiderverse with with a similar
infection because the second detail
revealed by Lord Miller was that Peter B
Parker who was seen with the BabyBjorn
in this trailer does indeed have a
daughter with Mary Jane a girl named
Mayday with two different colored eyes
and Lord Miller said that she inherited
her father's spider blood which is a
very important rule that they're
establishing if Mayday inherited her
father's spider blood wouldn't also
Gabriella have inherited Miguel's spider
blood and wouldn't that make both of
these spider daughters vulnerable to any
infection that threatens all spider
things this could have been how
Gabriella died also the case that Miguel
would make to Peter B Parker to pressure
him to side with him but again why
scapegoat miles well think about it
miles and Gwen are a pretty unique among
others in the spider-verse because their
universes started with a separate Peter
Parker before them a Peter who died and
handed off the mantle to them they were
not the first people bitten by a
radioactive spider and many others if
not most others in the spider-verse were
that first figure who were bitten by the
radioactive spider so that kind of makes
miles and Gwen anomalies or Miguel could
interpret mistakes or perhaps this movie
could even retcon that term inheritors
that causes a ripple effect to cross the
spiderverse revolting in Black Ink holes
the color black referring to the absence
of all other colors holes that have
begun to pockmark anyone on the arachno
frequency spectrum a disease super
spreaded by the spot that could be my
trailer footage shows miles and Gwyn in
Miguel O'Hara's device that seems to
cocoon them in this yellow and blue
crystalline structure a device that I
think might erase them by separating
their CMYK ink components back to their
separate Wells I don't know folks for a
story conceived during pandemic fears
seeking to use the elements of animation
and Artistry not just for aesthetic
Beauty but for tangible plot points in
the story this is one explanation that
makes a lot of sense to me but I want to
hear from you comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on Tick Tock
Hive Instagram and Twitter at EA boss
following the rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye and guys do not forget to download
fishing clash and use gift code
rockstars to get an awesome 20 value
reward for free and post the heaviest
fish that you catch in the comments
foreign
[Music]